what's going on everybody welcome to an
update to the neural networks from
scratch project
the content for neural networks from
scratch is
done so uh the only thing we're kind of
doing right now
is going through and reviewing for like
grammar issues and stuff like that
if you read the book uh like a month or
so ago
or more and you found certain chapters
such as
the derivatives or back propagation
uh confusing i strongly encourage and
suggest you to go back and read those
sections or wait for your book if you
ordered a physical copy
because those chapters specifically but
all of the chapters have been revamped
a lot so much so that i really would
call neural networks from scratch
already at like a v2
right now just simply because of all of
the feedback that we've gotten so we're
over 4 000 sales for ebook
softcover hardcover so we've had a lot
of people come through this this
document and part of what has taken so
long is arguably
we probably i mean we could have shipped
sooner
um but it would have been a lesser
product honestly
uh the changes that we have made um
especially recently with this kind of
like revamp when we went through again
have been pretty significant some of
these chapters have changed like more
than 50 percent so
huge huge update so i definitely
recommend
everyone goes back and reads if you're
confused anyways
also huge shout out and thanks to
everyone who both supported
the uh document as well as the
contributors a
special shout out to both thomas and
spencer who
have been helping with the editing
process especially spencer
most recently even like right now as i
film this
helping us find out all our little
grammar issues and stuff like that so
thank you to everybody
but we've had i i don't know the exact
number but we've had a huge number of
contributors
um so thank you to everybody who's made
contributions both in suggestions but
also just asking questions so
that's what's given us the ability to
see like okay a lot of people are having
a hard time with this specific section
let's update that section let's try to
word this in a different way and make it
easier to understand and so on so
um overall i'm super happy with
everything the whole format of us doing
it this way has been
absolutely phenomenal so now the only
delay
is with the hard copies of the books so
the hardcover and the softcover
we are i've been shipping myself demos
and daniel demos
uh and kind of the problem is it takes
me
two weeks to receive my demo uh it only
takes daniel
six days to receive his so a lot of
times we know about certain issues
really quick
and we can kind of have a sort of
rolling demo so i'm actually still
waiting on a demo book
um that daniel already got and i
actually or already ordered another demo
book
uh that actually i just sent to daniel
just because i wanted this
this process to go a little quicker but
it still takes a significant amount of
time and just to give you an idea i mean
there's some stuff that is like okay we
want a demo book just so we can see in
physical form
um things like margins and stuff like
that i am using adobe indesign for the
book
um but still things look different in
physical form compared to
uh like on a computer screen when you're
editing even though you know you can
make it look kind of like a book
and stuff like that in indesign uh it
just doesn't compare to
seeing it in physical form it really
does look different so
you definitely want to see it want to
get margins right especially like that
inside margin and stuff like that
so um definitely get those things done
but also
just to give an example the latest demo
that i sent daniel and myself
uh i updated the the main kind of neural
network image
on the cover that i sent to the
publishing company
and for some reason like our version of
the pdf looks great it looks like you
would expect it's nice
transparent image the image itself was
100 it was transparent
uh but somehow i send it in as pdf it
looks normal on the file that i sent in
but then once they do their conversion
on their end suddenly this image has a
background
so it looks pretty silly uh and i
definitely would not want thousands of
books with that problem
so um there's really no question in my
mind i gotta see
and ideally both me and daniel have to
see the
physical version of the book before we
send it out to thousands of people
because we're talking about
um i don't know the exact number all i
can say is it's over 50
as in 5-0 50 000 worth of books
so i'd rather not have some mega issue
um with that many books
i can't afford to make that mistake and
plus i wouldn't i just don't want to let
you guys down with
something like that that would be a
stupid problem so
um so yeah i have to see it um
and i really think both daniel and i
have to see it like some stuff obviously
like the book cover
um we both don't have to see it to know
that's a problem
um but anyway stuff like that i just
don't want that to happen
i can't order the book for everyone's
site on scene so
that's kind of in the works as we speak
my hope is the next big demo that we
send will be the full book to both
myself and daniel and then hopefully
within
hopefully the first week of october and
if not the first week
by the second week of october we start
shipping out the books but again the
content is all done if you bought
any version of the book that includes
the physical versions
and then obviously the ebook you get
access to the ebooks so
so if you're not in that group that
google group um
contact me let me know we'll get you in
that group you should have access to all
of the chapters not some people
think it's just chapter one it's all the
chapters the links are all there
also uh once we do the kind of final
pass of all the grammar checks i'll
convert it to a single file pdf download
that will be pretty quick for me to do
uh i also want to convert it to an epub
uh so you could read it on like an
ereader
but i suspect i'm i don't suspect i know
it's gonna require some different
formatting so that might take a little
longer to get done i mean i can put out
one that's
just like a converted version but it
won't be as clean as a
formatted specifically for version so uh
anyway that might take a little longer
but the pdf version will be put up
within pretty short order so you can
just download that but again if you have
questions
or something on the material you can go
to the google doc
and kind of ask them exactly in line
with that google doc
and i think that's a little more useful
so anyways i think that's everything i
want to cover uh
i thank you so much to everybody for
your support
and your patience with all of this i
haven't had anybody complain
that we've had to like push this
deadline a couple of times i think it's
because everyone has access to the ebook
um but still i'm surprised i'll probably
get some emails just because i said that
but but still thank you guys so much for
uh like i said the support in the
patients um
this is this is just such cool material
i'm so excited to be a part of it and i
know
daniel is super excited about it as well
and i just i can't wait to send
everybody their books i can't wait to
get my own version
i've got some demo books um but none of
the the demo books so far have only been
like 150 pages so they're not quite the
the uh bible that i expect it to be so
anyways uh stay tuned hopefully the next
time you
uh get an update on this it will be we
have shipped the books
uh so very very exciting so anyways uh
that's all for now questions comments
concerns whatever feel free to leave
below again if you're having any problem
accessing the material that you've
already purchased please email me that's
harrison
pythonprogramming.net and of course if
you want to buy the book
you can get it at nnfs.io
that's it see you guys next time